Russia bears responsibility
for the incident.
>> Today volodymyr zelenskyy
says he's convinced the missile
that landed in Poland was not
Ukrainian and has the doubts
from his own commander.
Matthew chance is at the site of
the strike and it's clear this
incident marks one of the
biggest tests of the nato
alliance in recent history.
>> Reporter: A Russian made
missile striking a nato ally and
setting the world on edge, but
it now seems the explosion that
killed two Polish farmers here
was a tragic accident, not as
feared ordered by the Kremlin.
>> The incident most likely
caused by Ukrainian air defense
missile fired to the Ukrainian
territory against Russian cruise
missile attacks.
But let me be clear, this is not
Ukraine's fault.
>> Reporter: Not Ukraine's fault
because its military was
defending against the barrage of
Russian missiles targeting
infrastructure and killing
civilians.
Among the victims was this
69-year-old woman visiting her
husband's grave in Kyiv when a
piece of shrapnel tore through
her body and killed her.
As wintersets in, it is reckless
abandon but what happens in
Poland shows how dangerous that
is for the whole world, too,
while Ukrainian officials are
redoubling request for more
advanced air defense systems
from the United States and
Europe.
They've also committed to C
cooperating with an
investigation and admitted the
air defenses were active in the
area but officials are clear,
Russian president Vladimir Putin
is responsible dragging
Ukrainians and a sleepily
one-street Polish town into his
war of choice.
Jake, teams of specialists from
both Poland and the united
States are still here trying to
piece together the fragments of
the missile that slammed into
this isolated Polish village but
tonight, concerns that incident
in a nato allied country,
remember, may spark a broader
conflict, definitely showing
signs most definitely of easing.
Jake.
>> Matthew chance in Poland for
us.
Thank you so much.
While Ukraine's president
volodymyr zelenskyy insists the
missile was not Ukrainian, it
was echoed in U.S. Intelligence
earlier today.
Take a listen.
>> Our preliminary analysis
suggests that the incident most
likely caused by Ukrainian air
defense missile.
>> CNN's Melissa bell is in
Brussels for us now.
She spent the day at nato
headquarters.
Poland is considering invoking
article 4 of the nato treaty
that calls for consultation that
can be invoked when any member
state feels threatened in any
way.
How is nato responding?
>> Reporter: The messaing today
was really in line with what
president Biden had to say on
his way out of the G 20 summit
when he left Bali, which is very
quickly while this investigation
continues, this was not a
missile fired by Russia really
trying to tone things down,
trying to stop anyone from
getting too excited about this.
We all arrived this morning Jake
hearing about the potential
invoking of article 4.
That's the beginning of
consultations and can lead to
article 5.
That's the foundational
principle of nato but of course,
what it means is an attack on
one country is an attack on all
and it would very quickly lead
to the kind of escalation that
everyone is worried about ever
since this invasion began and
nato stepped up to the plate to
help Ukraine.
So today was really at nato
headquarters trying to calm
everything down, not with
standing what president
zelenskyy was going, was saying
about what he believed has
happened and we've been hearing
that messaging fairly
consistently.
Consider, also, Jake, that
extraordinary unity we've seen
on the part of nato since this
conflict began, that we could
have imagined a year ago would
be severely tested and also,
Jake, things are going exactly